bonsoir les progammes merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors plutôt que d'élargir à tous les
plus de 50 ans 1 sans distinction le
gouvernement on l'a compris cible
toujours les plus fragiles a élargi sa
campagne de vaccination à d'autres
populations est ce que c'est la bonne
décision pour vous fallait accélérer le
rythme de cette manière c'est une
décision qui est logique puisque ce sont
les personnes qui sont plus à risque de
se retrouver à l'hôpital ou de mourir
cela dit ce ne sont pas ces personnes
qui transmettent le plus le virus et
plus des gens plus jeunes et actifs et
donc ce qu'on voit un peu partout en
réalité ces profils et c'est que tous
ceux qui ont envie de se faire vacciner
peuvent peuvent y aller
et donc c'est commencent à arriver
partout et je pense que finalement c'est
pas si mal que ça la seule limite
aujourd'hui c'est nombre de doses
vaccinales qui sont disponibles ça va
être quand même très très très dur
fin juin d'arriver à faire 30 millions
de personnes on a quand même deux mois
deux au moins de retard par rapport à
l'angleterre
la vie c'est plutôt juillet à y arriver
le gouvernement qui vise une immunité
collectif en août
ça me semble possible cette unité
collective est un mythe
en réalité puisque avec le nouveau
nouveau variant au lait nouveau variant
est il faut avoir à peu près 80% de la
population
immunisé pour l'éviter voire plus a et
donc on n'arrivera pas à ça à ce moment
là donc il va falloir se préparer à
vivre encore avec le virus pendant
l'automne à faire peut-être d'autres
types de vaccination troisième une
troisième dose et a continué à faire
attention
justement vous parlez des variants et
vous êtes très en pointe un sur les
techniques de séquençage est ce qu'on
commence en savoir davantage sur ces
différents variant dont on parle souvent
l'indien le brésilien qui font aussi
part alors nous dans les hauts de france
on étudie systématiquement mais de
manière aléatoire des prélèvements qui
ont été positifs en laboratoire de ville
pour l'instant on n'a trouvé ni indien
et on a plus de brasilia on a quelques
sud africain la situation n'est pas trop
mauvaise
le vario anglais commençent à muter on
ne sait pas trop ce que ça veut dire est
bon pour l'instant c'est plutôt
rassurant mais on a vu que on a laissé
entrer en france début avril des
personnes d'inde et qui sont atteints
par ce variant et il n'y a plus qu'à
espérer que ça restera dans certains
endroits et que ça va pas disséminés
quand on nous dit souvent ici ou là ces
variants sont plus dangereux plus
meurtrier même est ce que vous vous le
constatez honda on a vraiment
l'impression que dans les états où il ya
le plus de ce variant d'y indien et bien
c'est là où il ya plus de cas et le plus
de plus de mort et moi j'ai souvenir de
nos variés anglais les gens disent ah
mais non mais non il n'ya pas plus
dangereux et puis on s'est bien aperçu
quand on va éditer il l'était tout comme
le sud africain
il a un peu la sélection et ces virus
s'adapte et plus on aura une circulation
importante en france et plus on tarde à
on parlera à finir à la vaccination et
on risque de se retrouver avec une
situation compliquée avec des variantes
qui font on à la sortie de crise plus
difficile philippe rogué ça veut dire
que nécessairement les variants sont de
plus en plus dangereux à chaque fois on
pas forcément pas forcément mais ce
qu'on constate aujourd'hui surtout dans
les sociétés qui se vaccinent c'est que
ce sont ceux qui résistent le plus à la
vaccination
ils se transmettent le plus qui
survivent et en
il y a des variants qui sont moins
dangereux mais on les a pas vraiment
étudié et c'est un peu dommage parce que
c'était une des solutions aussi à voir
avec des virus très beaux actifs
on laisse se développer ce qui permet
d'avoir une unité collectif qui
fonctionne mais c'est pas ce qui s'est
passé là jusqu'à présent alors alors
qu'un quart de la population a été
vaccinée pour l'instant en france de la
première dose
le vaccin fader a été étudié pour les 12
15 ans est la suite logique il faut
aller le plus vite possible sur sur ce
plan c'est le début des des solutions
les adolescents sont peu malade mais son
transmetteur très important du virus à
leurs parents et leurs grands-parents
partout et donc à partir du moment où on
va difficilement arriver à cette
immunité dite collective avant la fin de
l'été mais probablement après la seule
solution sera de vacciner les
adolescents ont vraiment essayer
d'éradiquer cette pandémie
merci philippe regarde généticien
professeur à l'impérial collège de
londres et de l'université lille ii
d'avoir été avec nous et nous apporter
votre analyse sur la vaccination à ce
jour merci à vous